[Laughter]
hello Hi how are you good how about you
my name is Asia what's your name I'm
Grady
nice to meet you hello Hi how are you
good how about you good my name is Deja
what's your name I'm Grady
nice to meet you so off bat three words
that come to mind
you look beautiful
yo that girl's hot oh no no so off bat
three words that come to mind
[Music]
use it
oh I do make music you do do you make
music I play the trombone oh nice I sing
and I play guitar what are your red
flags
be honest I because my first time on a
date you know I don't really have any
red flags yeah
[Music]
yeah no one ever came to me or no luck
on the dating sites you know so you're
the guy that likes the girls to come to
him or I just haven't found the right
one yet okay okay it's not that he likes
girls to come to him is that every time
he's yes or girl she's just said no
or he was too afraid to ask a girl out
it's not that he's difficult he just has
no luck
and you're the first one who's had like
a long conversation with him and sat
there and it's because you kind of had
to when you got into that thing so yes
but he's pretty much preparing himself
for the button to be pressed oh yeah
yeah yeah
sorry
there was no way to do it but I feel
like that way was not the right one
and
yeah
there was no way to do it but that one
was not the one you know I just had no
luck in dating I feel like
it's just dating is really difficult and
there's been very few opportunities for
me to meet people and so yeah well this
is no luck
you're good why did you reject Grady he
said only has been on one date I don't
want to like ruin him he's so sweet
how are you I'm good nice to meet you
nice to meet you my name is Jason Jason
I'm Deja nice to meet you Deja damn you
do smell good who said that give each
other a little sniff
[Music]
give each other a lift
didn't specify where I got to sniff you
how are you doing legs up
you passed a sniff test fun fact Jason
kicks his chin hairs out oh it's just
something I do at the time like if I'm
sitting there watching TV I'll just go
like this
okay you want a secret I picked my
eyelashes out oh look when I'm bored
like
you pick your eyelashes out to implant
brand new ones after that that makes
perfect sense my girl that's a jail and
then help me commission I thought I was
the only weird one
it's all good you're handsome thank you
you're beautiful I didn't know what to
say you look you look amazing you got
great teeth thank you like I don't know
what to say because like just looking at
you and all that I'm like
so you make me like
awkward virginity like stuff is cute if
he's cute yeah the other dude was like I
haven't been on a team it's my first
time I'm shaking just looking at you
stop no if she likes them it's cute but
if she don't he's weird but if you know
what I wish right now what that he does
all that and he Buzz her he just might
but I don't think he will
go down to his chin
yeah
I can show you like
[Music]
win-win
I'm not hitting it after that hey
that pong along
[Laughter]
she saw that said okay how deep is your
love
[Music]
about to get it yeah
let's talk about age oh okay
I'm 22.
[Music]
the selling point for me with him is
that he seems really mature for his age
you haven't dated an older woman though
so you don't really know if you like it
exactly so y'all it's all like learning
experience
so
that's all are you gonna teach him so
I mean I could but you could teach me a
lot more so I don't know all right I
have a proposition
this is going well right yeah are you
willing to go on two other dates and if
those don't go well I'll bring bunriko
back
okay we
do you think the other two guys might
win her over
I hope not
all right let's check on it
all right
what are your thoughts
I don't like that
I don't like that
oh I know why you don't like that and
you know what I would have liked I think
the button should have said if you guys
are down with this agreement I'm going
to hit the light and make a red if you
guys both agree that's what we'll do and
I would have pressed the button right
then and there you know what it feels
like
you know what it feels like it feels
like this girl is the friend of the
producer
and he's working in her best interest
because no it never in the history of
the button have we seen oh what we're
gonna do is accommodate you why would
they accommodate her I'm just putting
that [ __ ] on the whole point of the
button is that you press it and then you
go on to the next person yes you might
be missing out but you're looking for
something better the fact that she can
not only see what else is out there
because she's unsure about this guy but
then also get to go back I just hope
that if she does speak two other dudes
and she don't like them that she brings
him back and then he buzzes her or that
when the two dice because I don't know I
don't like that I agree if this happened
to me in real life I would be insulted I
said [ __ ] if you shout out to other
guys then go away yeah why you gotta
give him a better try yeah it defeats
the purpose of the button yeah but if he
agrees I mean he's gonna agree because
he's 21. he want to sniff something yeah
but me
it couldn't be me
making me look imagine imagine if they
okay
you don't want to do this too often but
you flip the genders ladies weren't you
feeling so yeah forget forget it I know
guys a lot of guys would accept this
because they just want some [ __ ] but
like ladies would you forget the girl
the whole internet is gonna trash the
dude yeah they won't like it I mean they
don't like it that might ask me yes
I like that
these are cool nice to meet you I'm a
mama's boy for sure
I think that's kind of a positive though
mama's boy okay what makes your mama's
boy uh I my mom is like a great mom for
sure um I was just she was she raised me
and my sister as a single mom and I
think that kind of built our connection
oh okay and that's that's the vulnerable
part there I love that
I just got you got to read it yeah there
is something beautiful about the button
how fake people will be like oh yeah oh
you're a mo I love that
which is awesome it really does speak to
the fact that yeah people say whatever
they want but given the option next to
you to find something better they will
they will even they're giving you all
those sweet nothings that's why some of
you must be saying Abba he said so many
kind things to me
why would a ghost because the button the
button
do you understand it now but why
couldn't he just be the button
what is it this show explains it all got
it right last date if you're still into
what's his name Federico bomb Rico
something Rico
are those you feel eyes they are wow
where did that come from honestly I
don't know I'm mixed with a whole lot of
things but I'm also learning to be a
bartender so I just started bartender
[Music]
if you were to make a drink for me what
would you make have you ever had a lemon
drop when I was 21. oh wait how do you
know
okay all right you got me all right
that's pretty good all right you gotta
pass okay sister
hey my name is Rico too
[Music]
I'm sorry
I understand but your eyes are beautiful
thank you you're gorgeous thank you so
much I hope it's about the Hat the
hatter the drink selection as usually
gonna be I think it's the drinks I think
it's the hand how do you pronounce your
name again
ask her do you remember my name
yeah on Rico what's her name
[Music]
it's still here
I'm still here for you and he went oh
hopeful
I can't stop looking at you yeah I'm
like okay this is good
all right I'm gonna light up one last
time and if you don't press you win
[Music]
he wants some [ __ ]
why don't you gonna press this button
[Music]
how messed up would it be
congratulations you have won the button
yeah there you go see sometimes we get
our predictions wrong
shout out to the first guy the Virgin
dude
shout out to him I I never been on a
date before I want to raise my odds at
rejection by going on the bus you know
you know what the problem is what I
already forgot them that's probably what
the problem is I'll never forget you
Grady uh listen man I'm praying for you
uh next time you're looking for love and
companionship don't go on the button
probably one of the worst ways to meet
people so yeah feel free but it is what
it is
it was it was it was not I don't know it
was not fulfilling it wasn't fun that
was not fulfilling there was not enough
drama not it was not enough yeah it was
not enough rejection it's like
it's like
it's
like
you want a chicken fried rice and
there's no chicken
okay there's not enough meat
if I want to fried rice I'd add fried
rice I only a little bit you know I mean
more people it's like they were running
out of people maybe I wanted a drama
it's not running drama I want more like
diversity it was just one girl it was
one girl four guys that that's the
episode one girl four guys that's not
the button that's not the button that's
the choice that's what it is which one
you wanted that's the bachelorette
that's not that's a whole last other
show that I don't even like it's not the
button it's the choice
I mean that ain't her fault though I'm
not saying it's her fault I'm not
blaming that [ __ ] on her yeah I'm just
saying I mean you know what I think it's
great I think it's great because it
shows how much dudes really want to get
with a cute girl it's fair
that's what I come down to with your
person yeah absolutely no I mean these
girls these she did not have any
chemistry with most of those dudes
except of doing that she was one and
these guys still sat there like there's
no like I'm I'm hoping
[ __ ] if I was the third or fourth dude
I'd buzzer just on principle one time
for my [ __ ] that would have been me
person but from what I understand it's
like this was probably the end of the
episode like they did a whole bunch of
them and then they kept that one at last
and for the last episode but all these
[ __ ] were there before
maybe maybe uh as far as I'm concerned
that's fantastic yeah Grady stay alive
rest of them uh
more part of you yeah let us know what
you guys think